so I want to use this object is our case
study for the next thing right I've
actually said this a couple of times it
slipped out of my tongue because I've
forgotten that we haven't covered it in
this class yet but I've said when
referring to something like this I've
actually just said more than just it's
the derivative I've actually said the
phrase I don't know how many of you
caught it I've said first derivative
which kind of implies well how many
other derivatives are there now once you
differentiate once you get a function
differentiating is just the process like
it's a rule you can apply it as many
times as you'd like okay so if I were to
differentiate again what useful
information would it give me well let's
have a go at this I'm going to start
from here three x squared minus three
I'm not going to use this line because
well it doesn't really matter but I'm
gonna differentiate the derivative okay
now I need to introduce some notation
for you so just make a little subheading
notation okay we talked about three
different objects that are the most
important way to trying to understand a
function right you talked about the
original function you talked about the
first derivative and then because you're
differentiating again we call this next
thing no prizes for guessing the second
derivative you can go ahead you can find
a third or a fourth or the fifth it just
turns out that those are not that useful
or interesting I mean you can use them
for things but we don't need them really
so these are the three objects I'm
interested in now based on how you start
off your notation you use slightly
different notation to move forward so
for instance if you think way back to
when we did first principles we talked
about function notation remember that f
of X okay what do we apply what symbol
do we apply to get your first derivative
a dash so we call this f dash so if you
were to differentiate again will you
just put another - so you can have F
Double Dash alright
that's another way of writing the second
derivative
likewise usually the same notation if I
call the Y instead of f of X we've seen
y dash before we've also seen y double
dash like that okay now f of X
they're just labels I can call functions
whatever I like later on you're going to
encounter actually the function you're
differentiating is called X I know
that's a bit weird but you'll usually
differentiate that with respect to time
it's something we'll get to in motion
it's related to physics okay in that
context rather than music dashes I don't
know physicists they actually use a dot
right over the top so this is their
symbol for saying differentiate with
respect to time differentiate what's
that's called X dot no prizes for
guessing if you differentiate again
you'd call it X double dot and there's
two dots it looks like a weird awkward
emoji okay there you go
so these are all ways of shade
differentiate once differentiated game
okay now none of these is my favorite
the favorite one that I have the last
one it looks the most awkward but the
reason I like it is because it's the
most informative it tells you the most
about what's going on okay so I'm going
to come back to using wine right the
first derivative we call it the gradient
function right because it tells you the
gradient at any point on the curve and
so that's why I think the most helpful
descriptive definition or notation is dy
or DX because it literally tells you
it's rise over run yeah rise over run
now think about this first second just
put your pens down what this means is
you know how like Oh dash dash is a
little piece of notation you add on to
the wine you can do as many times as you
like dot is a little bit of notation you
just add it on to whatever your function
is called what is the piece of notation
that's been added on to Y to turn it
into this and the answer is remember
it's this guy it's D on DX right you see
you literally apply that to Y and look
the Y appears here it's dy DX does that
make sense so this is and I did say this
phrase earlier we call this the
differential operator now if I do this
again if I do this a second time to this
this is what happens you do this about
this
does that make sense I'm taking that
thing that's the first derivative bless
you and I'm differentiating it again
okay well have a look at this right all
in the numerator because these are
fractions right on the numerator you see
I have the letter D twice right it's D
and then the difference and then the
difference again okay so what I right at
the top is d squared Y okay you see
there's the DVD again on the bottom you
see how there's two DX's right so it's
actually DX and then DX again so it
really shouldn't be written don't write
this just watch it should be written as
that because she there's two DX is the
whole thing gets repeated but
mathematicians lazy they write that okay
so a lot of people don't like this
because it's well you look at the whole
set of things there it's a it's the
longest and hardest and most awkward to
write of this entire scheme like so but
I stand by what I said before I think
it's the most descriptive when I talk
about it that's the one that I will
always go to it also is a nice thing it
tells you what the variables are for
example I said to you hey this function
here is why but you don't know if it's
in terms of X or R or T or s or who
knows whereas this one tells you exactly
what you're dealing with okay so this is
my favorite but you need to be able to
recognize all of them okay so now you
know what these things now you know how
to talk about these things now the
question is well what are the first and
second videos you got the first one here
I need some space what is the second
derivative of this function have a look
what do you get
it's a very simple function have a look
it's just six X that's it
okay 6x